to be here
after such a long time uh with this
covet break that we had
i'm actually spending uh uh most of my
time this these days in optum labs which
is part of united health group and
i'm gonna talk today about a work from
ucla uh and just kind of briefly mention
what we're doing also in optum in the
beginning uh the main
relation between the two things is
uh is actually
actually before i go there uh the title
is whole genomic deletion patterns as
biomarkers for ehr imputation
uh and i'll try to show you in the at
the end of the talk that uh
there's a kind of is this working yes
the whole genome here
is what we're using but it's not really
clear that that's what we need
that's basically uh necessary
at least for some preliminary results
that we have right now
uh so okay so
uh so this is actually one of the uh
so the main thing that kind of we're
interested in in both uh side of my with
my two hats essentially which is
basically trying to find
uh to do disease prediction using any
type of of data that we can get our
hands on
uh and it's not necessarily just
genomics data in the ucla lab but we're
uh focusing mostly on
uh
on the genomics but not only
but in principle that's kind of the
the holy grail right if we basically
would be able to look at the diagnosis
the to to take the data
get to prognosis and diagnosis of the
patient personal level and then
understand what treatment is and in a
perfect world we'll have all this
information and actually have in a
really perfect world we'll have
all the molecules of of the patient
basically screen somehow and and get
kind of a
multi-dimensional information about this
in in reality what we have is this kind
of things
uh which is you know starting from the
right because i'm from israel so
um
genomics uh
imaging for pathology or for
other types of radiology ophthalmology
and so on
uh and um
physiological waveforms that we get in
the icu and so on and of course the
medical records which is kind of a
incomplete
picture of what we of the of the patient
so just a couple of uh examples for some
projects that we've done in the lab in
the last few years that are not related
to genomics and then i'm going to go
into the genomics so this is an example
for just
what we did here which which is
essentially imputing
uh blood continuous blood pressure using
uh
ppg and ecg waveforms
uh there's actually for these patients
we also have the genetic data but we
didn't really find a way to actually
make it better
but this is something that happens in in
uh
when people go to the icu or to the uh
to the or and the their high-risk
patients then we want to we want to know
what their
uh wave wave uh what what the blood
pressure is continuously and not just
measure it every five minutes
uh and so for that you typically what
you do is you have you do an
interventional
uh procedure which is basically put a
catheter then you measure them
continuously and the idea here is can we
do it just with ecg and ppg
which is essentially non-invasive
uh so this is one example another
example is with a medical imaging in
this case ophthalmology which is again
trying to basically use
the data that we have and for these ones
also we have some genetic data but we
couldn't find
how to use the genetic data to improve
the results so far it doesn't mean that
it's not there we just don't know how to
do it which is essentially going into
the in this case the three-dimensional
imaging of the eye of the retina
and trying to understand what in which
stage is the patient in terms of their
age-related macro degeneration so
that's these are two examples and um
we are thinking about basically how to
to uh to include
the genetics what i'll talk about today
is more on the ehr side and basically
thinking about how to use the ehr
in um
and machine learning
in order to predict disease and so we've
done
a bunch of works around that and one of
the steps the main steps in this in all
these works is
trying to figure out how to use how to
deal with the fact that the data is
sparse
so ehr data is sparse and
that's true for any ehr system that i've
seen so far
just because uh patients are basically
not showing up every day to the to the
clinic right and so
uh one of the things that we can do is
try to do imputation and i'm gonna try
to talk about this today
the tricky thing unlike genomics is that
when you look at ehr data in uh
the sparsity in hr data the missingness
is not random
so uh
in
many cases in genomic data it's actually
maybe not always true in genomics but in
many cases in genomic data we can assume
that when we don't see a specific
variant or we don't see there's a no
call
that's kind of a random thing it doesn't
happen because of something else that
happens to the patient but in ehr we're
not going to test we're not going to
send someone to an mri if they don't
have a problem right we don't for most
for the most part we don't do screening
so it's not always true there's some
screening but in 99.9 of the cases there
is no screenings and so the fact that
you don't see something you don't have a
test that actually tells you something
that said all the methods that are used
right now or at least most of them
there's been some work trying to kind of
alleviate this but basically most of
them are essentially kind of ignoring
this this uh this fact
uh and so for example basically uh one
of the uh one of the most typical ways
is to do matrix completion which
essentially assumes doesn't take into
account this causality issue or this
this fact that you have none
uh
that the missingness is nothing run and
so the question that we can ask is
basically can we use genomics in this
case to do imputation so what is
imputation in this case it's really just
prediction of what the patient has at
this this point in time
so that's been done
uh
many times actually
and many people have looked at this uh
from the genetic perspective
and the kind of most widely used though
my widely studied uh
approach is called polygenic phylogenic
risk for which is
basically taking uh all the snaps of the
variants in the genome and summing them
up linearly
so that if you see uh just in this
example here you have three variants uh
the first the third and the seven so you
add up
three numbers a1 plus a3 plus a7 you get
a score
you do this for the second one the third
one and so on and again every patient
has a score now which is just a linear
model across the
in this case that would be snips but any
set of variants basically
now of course when you do this then it's
very easy to overfit so you basically
want to either think about
regularization or think about other
approaches that basically take this and
there's a lot of
studies on how to take into account
linkage disequilibrium so basically
correlation and things so it's not as
easy as i show it here but that's the
basic idea the basic idea here is you
have
this prs that then you have a
distribution in the population of these
scores and you hope that high-risk
patients are going to be basically here
okay so
one of the ways
that we could basically get better and
better at doing these trs polygenic risk
scores is getting these
this
biobank so this in this slide here it's
basically describing the ucla health
bio bank there's many others obviously
i'm sure people know about the uk
biobank and there's
a few other institutions on the basic
institutions that built uh biobanks of
this order of magnitude within even more
in ucla basically we have 150 000 people
in the athletes called atlas the the
biobank
and
what we have over there is we keep the
samples the dna samples for each of the
patients
so we don't keep the entire
uh
the blood sample
but we basically extract the dna
and that's important because if you
wanted to do now an rna study on this
population that would be that would
require another collection
while if you want to do anything related
to
the dna
for example methylation you basically
can use just these samples
and that's essentially what we did
so some limitations of uh the prs so
um
the first one is is pretty obvious which
is basically the genetics doesn't
capture environment so that essentially
means that whatever i can predict about
a person now i could have predicted it
also when the person was born
so if i want to ask what the patient has
right now it's kind of you know it's
maybe important to understand what is
the kind of total risk of the patient to
have a heart attack sometime in their
life
but i don't know
necessarily unless i have uh um unless
it's the age of onset is very heritable
i don't really know exactly what's going
on right now with this patient
okay so that's that's one limitation
um
i guess the second
i guess i mentioned the second one here
the first one is so okay so the first
one is basically mostly an environment
which is essentially if someone smokes i
wouldn't see it the second one is really
the fact that it's static
and then the third one is basically that
if you just look at the kind of the
proof is in the pudding prs is not
really used by clinicians today and it's
not that we tried it only for a year or
two we basically
we i'm in the community basically
we've been looking at it for many years
now
and still if you look at the clinic it's
not released
so there could be other reasons it's not
necessarily that the prediction is not
good but if the position was excellent
and it was very useful that probably we
would be
we would be using this
so then what we ask is can methylation
be another approach to uh to do kind of
a prs
or mrs ventilation risk or
uh where we basically are trying to do
essentially the same thing
so methylation for those of you are less
familiar basically is a biomarker with
these are modifications
in the dna
uh in
uh across the entire genome and every
cell so unlike genetics basically
genetics every so dna
so when you look at genetic data every
cell has the same
genetics
roughly almost uh in methylation
essentially every cell has a different
one there are some correlations if
there's the same if there are similar
cell types and things like this but
basically every cell is going to have a
different methylation pattern
and there's been a lot of work over the
last
few decades i guess
showing correlation to diseases and the
fact that it captures demographics so
for example you can basically there's
differences major differences between
women and men
even when you look at the autosomes
uh it can capture ancestry
uh so there's a and it captures really
well aged so basically steve robert um
from ucla basically did a
work which is i think maybe 10 15 years
now where you can it could show that you
you have a very uh high correlation
between age and methylation patterns
the other thing is that it's uh
inexpensive although today everything is
inexpensive because you can do a
the genome for 100 bucks but basically
it's been inexpensive for a long time
now for the last 10 years
at least
so the data for methylation basically
looks kind of like this in every
if you think about the matrix of
individuals you'll have individuals and
methylation sites and you'll have a
number between zero and one that will
tell you what is the frequency of the
methylation
in uh
in the samples that you're looking at
for that individual at that position so
these are positions in the genome
uh
typically people use this methylation
arrays that
one we use basically has eight hundred
thousand a bit more than eight hundred
thousand uh positions that we're looking
at
okay so then the questions can we use
instead of genetics can we use
methylation for
uh imputation and so that's what we're
trying to
to answer here and so why is this
promising
so methylation actually does
does capture some of the environment
maybe a lot of it actually so for
example smoking
would be
something that you'll be able to find
using methylation so to at least some
correlation to how much people smoke and
there's essentially basically everything
that happened not everything but a lot
of things that happened to the patient
uh which are not necessarily something
that they were born with
are going to either change the
methylation or the methylation is going
to change that
either way it doesn't really matter the
causality there's going to be some
correlation
the other thing is that methylation is
dynamic as i said basically you can
capture age for example so it changes
over time
it's actually nice motilation is a nice
biomarker in the sense that it changes
typically over months and not over not
within hours not within days
and so that basically means that you can
capture kind of the information about
the patient over the last few months if
you think about it intuitively
and then
unlike prs for genetics methylation
if you look at all these biobanks they
essentially don't have any methylation
data
and so there's no uh
it hasn't been really studied and
personally i don't really understand why
but
hopefully i can convince you now that
maybe maybe now we should start doing
this
so the basically what we tried is very
simple we tried to look at instead of a
prs which is just a linear uh sum of uh
genetics data now we're looking at p at
mrs
the sum of beta i mi which is mi is the
modulation at position i
uh and then we we measured this over 800
uh so that 800 is after some cleaning
and some pruning but basically 800
patients from the atlas population so we
had also the genetic data and we had all
the ehr data for this population
this population actually that we took
are these are people that went to
surgeries
and we
looked at the risk for
aki
aki
kidney injury after surgery so they all
had some kind of and that's how we match
them basically and uh they all had some
issues that are related to the kidney
uh and actually some of our best results
are basically in predictions of kidney
uh kidney uh problems
okay so and then the the method is very
standard we basically just used regular
regression we tried to we tried multiple
versions so uh ridge lasso elastic and
then we also
try to combine the genetics and the
methylation so all everything that
you could think of as as kind of
reasonable to try
and we compared it to uh to a baseline
which is basically regression over these
features here which is the the kind of
demographics
some information about so bmi and then
celtic proportions which is an important
fit that actually changes
the methylation patterns globally
the ancestry smoking status and and 10
top pieces of the genetics
okay so that's our population so again
800 people we had some
[Music]
diversity uh but still 70 80 percent of
the people were vocations
um our goal originally was to basically
just look at latinos but we just didn't
have enough people that were
kind of matched everything that we
needed
so we ended up with this kind of uh uh
mix
and uh uh and the you know the
populations are a little bit on the
older side
so basically they're skewed to the right
a bit and the reason is because these
are people that basically going to
uh
to surgery so
they actually visited the hospital for a
specific reason
okay so these are the results
kind of uh
that we got just a summary of those and
what you can see is so i'll give you
just an example so this we looked at
about 600 different
uh
parameters in the ehr including
medications
um ficos which is essentially a
combination of or groupings of icd codes
so diagnosis codes so these are you can
think about it as disease
and labs
and every point here is one of these
labs one of these diseases
and
this what you see on the x-axis is what
the baseline gave just a simple
regression of just these 10
features and the y-axis is what we got
with the prs or with the mrs so a point
that is on the diagonal
is basically not doing better than
uh than just the base the
uh baseline
and what you can see is that the mrs
gives you in many cases not all the
cases but in many cases you get things
that are above the back on the diagonal
so it's pretty significant
and it's only with 800 samples so we
didn't do 150 000
or 500 000 like the uk by rank it's a
very small number compared to what we're
used to with genetics
these are specific examples where you
can basically see
uh for these specific phenotypes what
happens when you look at the r-square of
the
genotypes compared to the prs compared
to the mrs
uh and these are basically just
combining those into the predicted uh
deciles compared to actually what's the
fraction of the cases in each of these
the cells so ideally in an ideal
situation you have
everyone on the right side
right so
and you can see that there's more of a
push of this in the methylation
case so if i just take the 10 top 10
percent
in the methylation risk course i'll get
that 70 of the cases are actually here
while in the prs it's only going to be
40
okay so i have a few of these slides i'm
going to go through
quickly through a couple of those
so these are just
some examples for some of the kind of
highlights some places that just kind of
to show that in some cases it was very
substantial the differences
uh and you can see that some of these
things are related to kidney
uh by definition or kind of
by the bias of what we
of a certain and centralized i guess but
these are true results it's just
basically we had more power to do it
when we look at uh kidney
kidney related issues
okay so um
one one of the things that basically
asked ourselves is that people are
actually using when they look at
imputation if we that that was kind of
our original goal that you look at
matrix completion
and we're now coming up with we're
comparing to prs but nobody's using prs
even though we would like to say that
people would
people don't use it because it's not
there the data is not there so people
use
these matrix completion methods and the
questions can we
add to the to the matrix completion the
methylation and how much do we gain like
that
so
the
um
what we did is a very simple thing we
took
basically the matrix which is the kind
of with the missing data
and we added the methylation risk scores
kind of the matrix on the side
and so now we have a much bigger matrix
that basically half of it essentially
has some data and half of it has missing
data
and then we just basically put it into
the matrix completion obviously this is
not the optimal way to do this it's
actually a pretty lousy way to do this
but we just wanted to see how
how that works
um and it's it seems like basically just
even that
actually gives you a pretty nice
improvement in performance
in many cases so again not not always
but i'm pretty optimistic that if we try
to optimize this we would actually
be improving some of these results as
well
okay
um i'll i think i have
what is it
eight more minutes
so yeah so this this figure here
basically shows that just kind of i'll
give you just the gist of it it
basically shows that
if you try some of the um things that we
try to predict
let's say an icd code so the diagnosis
code maybe happens six months before we
actually took the modulation data so you
can ask yourself how well do we predict
something that basically uh the lab or
medication or anything that basically we
try to predict that the event happened
six months ago it didn't happen right
now
so obviously if something happened five
years ago then your chances are much
typically much lower it depends actually
if it's a disease maybe it continues
but if it's kind of a lab that maybe you
have a spike or something like this you
shouldn't you shouldn't be able to see
this but we actually see that for the
most part
the what we get in terms of the
prediction when we go back here
it basically gives us very similar
results so it's the the results are
maintained even if you go back
a few months
okay and the other thing we had again
some diversity so we compared basically
the results across the different
relations
as you can see the confidence intervals
are huge and the reason is because our
samples are small
it's only 800 people and so i don't know
if you can basically
conclude that there's no differences in
mutilation risk because in prs there are
actually differences between when you
look at different populations but there
the numbers
are much larger
so maybe if we go to a hundred thousand
and then we do the ventilation rates go
based on a hundred thousand we'll see
differences but at least with these
sample sizes we don't really see
differences
so just remember that we had like a
maybe 100 or 50 between 50 to 100
african-americans okay five minutes
okay so
um and again for those of you who are
interested in building biobanks i know
some of you are
if you look at this at these figures
here and you basically try to kind of
sam sample the data and say instead of
800 people if you only had 400 people
what would be the result then instead of
800 if you have 200 you can basically
try to see
how the uh
how things are basically going to change
over time so in this case if you look at
the baseline for instance it doesn't
really matter so the baseline is just
taking the
the demographics and the bmi and so on
uh so it doesn't really matter so if you
took a 800 or 400 it's essentially the
same results
but if you look at the methylation risk
scores in some cases it actually it
seems like we're just in the beginning
so if we if we went from 800 to 8000
probably the results would be way better
okay so i'll just finish with a couple
of things when i put this picture for
rodrik here
um so this is a work in progress
the really kind of uh fresh out of the
oven so still maybe uh buggy although i
think it's pretty safe
uh what we try to ask ourselves is
basically can you so what we did so far
is just a simple methylation risk of
using linear models so we tried all
kinds of linear models but the question
is can you actually use uh non-linear
models and get better results
then
than just looking at the linear modes
and so we have this uh this
linear this nonlinear model which is
essentially a neural network which is
built this way
we have a set of genes actually in this
example here
that i'm going to show we took 30 genes
and these genes that we chose so you
could do it across the entire genome but
so far what we did is we took genes that
are associated with with the condition
and so for each of these genes you build
a
neural network which is in this case a
fully connected neural network very
relatively shallow
you don't want to add too many
parameters because then you're going to
overfit very easy
and then you get essentially a bit or
score from each of those so a number
from each of these genes
so now if i have 30 genes or if i have
20 000 genes i'm going to have 30
numbers or 20 000 numbers depending on
the number of genes you're going to look
at
and and then you basically put all of
them into another fully connected
neural network
that includes these numbers plus
information about demographics the
genotyping sees in the setup composition
kind of like what we had in the in the
baseline
and then uh we either we tried either
adding the mrs
or not adding the mrs so you
may be saying okay let's try to add mrs
and see if it actually helps
or just basically let's just ignore it
and see what these 30 genes give us
and so that was i was what i was hinting
in the beginning
so this is the what these are the
results we have so far so random force
actually gives you nothing
um
if you do uh just ridge across these
this population so this these genes
uh that's what you get about 0.6
and then if you go if you look at the
neural network without the mrs and the
neural network without with the mrs
they're actually doing about the same
so in fact in this case 30 genes gave
you the information
from a predictive perspective which is
essentially almost or
i mean it's hard to save because again
the numbers are maybe too small
um
if there's a difference but definitely
comparable compared to
the other approaches
okay so
these are again work in progress and
we've only done it on a couple of uh
examples because for each of those we
had to go and look for the genes it's
like it requires some more work
but i think it looks promising in the
sense that kind of the non-linear models
if you just looked at the linear model
so there's two kind of messages here one
of them is if you just look at the
linear model that's not going to get you
to where you want to be so the
non-linearity actually helps
and the other thing is that between
these two
maybe we don't actually need the entire
genome we need to basically choose the
the parts of the genome or kind of
wisely and in this case using the
literature uh
maybe there is another way to use the
entire genome but uh
you know at least right now we don't
really see an advantage for this from
these examples so
okay so
conclusions i have like two more minutes
or i'm done one more minute okay so just
basically complete conclusion so i'm
uh i'm thinking
you know at least
hopefully i was able to convince that
methylation can basically give some a
good signal
uh i'm going to risk it and say that
hopefully we could basically find a
universal blood test and i'm
kind of
in the
just uh
red red
uh bad blood just recently which is
it's so it's kind of scary to say that
but basically so not terranos but really
uh universal blood blood is in the sense
that it will give us some idea of
basically what's going on with the
patient without actually doing one you
know 1000 things to the patient
so there's many different things that
you could do to try to improve i
mentioned a couple of them so increasing
the population side that's an obvious
thing
right so base and i think that that what
i i would
urge everybody that is working on this
these biobanks to think about doing even
if you go to ten thousand it's ten times
more than what we did and it's not so
much money today
um
non-linear models as i said an
improvement of uh improving the soft uh
essentially the matrix completion we use
the software called soft compute but
basically you could use others for
matrix
completion and then from a biological
perspective
what we showed are just correlations and
it would be interesting to understand
what is the kind of causality what
causes these predictions
and so basically some type of mediation
has a causality
and then another idea would be to
basically look at cell type specific
because again we know that the
methylation data has this kind of
composition of all of these things
together of all of these cell types
together
all right so uh
thank you for your uh attention and this
is basically based on most of it is
based on the paper that mike thompson
from my lab was actually going to
barcelona
next year
and brian hill from lab basically lead
and then oren
did the non-linear models that i
mentioned just
just now and then the others basically
helped as well thank you
[Applause]
thank you aaron uh i think we can do one
quick question because we will go for
coffee break yeah
thanks aaron that's really nice i was
wondering did you already you know
before you do mediation causality just
break down the features that are picked
up in meditation area into
tagging cell type composition the
methylation clock you know i mean
there's lots of knowledge about which
features are tagging specific properties
of a sample and this is did you already
do that to get an insight what you
actually do yeah
no we actually haven't because what we
did is kind of a screening across
everything and we to do this you would
basically have to go to each one of them
specifically because i'm my unless we
think that there's going to be something
universal in that sense my my intuition
would be that for age there's going to
be specific specific mechanisms and for
you know type 2 diabetes that would be
you could just break down the feature
relevance you know in these broad
categories for different traits
i think that would be
super important and no we haven't done
it yet
uh let's thank our speakers again and um
if you have questions let's move this
discussion to the corporate thank you
thank you